can you say again I could kill you oh
yeah I'm ready
oh good okay great so so yeah our next
speaker this is Peter Rendell we are
very happy to have him he's uh he was he
was a student at Oregon State and now he
is a researcher at visa research he has
done a lot of work on through applied
cryptography specifically instead of
multi-party computation and homomorphic
encryption and and you can tell us about
all the work that he did on so efficient
private said intersection from my on the
market encryption so take it away Peter
yeah thanks
yeah this is full of work that came out
of grad school I was working on a
private site in rich section and then
Kim Lane supposed to be for an
internship at Microsoft and they were
doing a bunch of fhe work and so he sort
of merged our two where our head spaces
were and this is so the work that came
out of it and zico also helped and he
was at university at the time
so most you probably know what privacy
intersection is but if you don't it
refers to the problem of typically with
two parties each holding a set X&Y and
they wish to learn the intersection of
the sexes without revealing any
additional information about this sets
themselves in particular we'll consider
the scenario where there's a sender
party and a receiver party each possess
a set and the receiver should learn the
intersection of the set and but they
shouldn't learn any additional
information about X and the sender
shouldn't learn anything at all this is
sort of the ideal functionality that we
are aiming for and all throughout this
talk I'll use this diamond notation to
refer get functionality
and we consider this a classic
real-world ideal world scenario where we
have a figurative trusted third party
that's computes this function for us but
in reality the parties actually will be
sending messages back and forth and
we'll consider two types of parties some
can be a semi honest and basically what
this means is they'll send the correct
messages during the protocol or well
first construct a semi on this protocol
and then then later we will consider
malicious security where one of the one
or both the parties will arbitrarily
deviate and then we'll see what what
type of guarantees we can achieve but
first let's consider some of the
motivating applications for why we want
to do private set intersection one well
maybe one of my favorite applications is
actually being used in the wild by
Google and here Google has some say
Tesla signs up to advertise the cars on
Google and so Google shows the
advertisement to some set of users and
then Tesla on their hands sees that they
have some set of customers that came and
actually bought a Tesla in the store and
now you'd like to be able to correlate
who solve the ad and came in and bought
the Tesla so that you could sort of get
some sort of idea about how how
effective the advertising is and the
challenge is here is that neither of
these parties are really willing to
share the customer information with the
other so you sort of get into a sticking
point and so here you could run private
set intersection between the two sets
and sort of only the customers that saw
the ad and bought the car yield and
what's more Google actually doesn't feel
a little bit fancier where they only
don't reveal the intersection itself but
they do a little post-processing and
they reveal how many dollars to the
customers spend or how many customers
thoughts are not message individual
clusters themselves and we'll see how to
do this at the very end of the pocket
enough
another great example is like someone
could be registered to vote in this
upcoming election in more than one state
and that's uh actually illegal it's only
illegal if you vote in both states but
maybe you'd like to be able identifying
these voters who may accidentally got
registered in two states and then see if
they can be removed from one of them and
here again for privacy reasons might
wouldn't want to reveal all the all the
registered voters to you know States
until psi can be used here um and maybe
the most relevant application that we'll
be looking at is known as contact
discovery so here say we we have some
messaging app in this case what's that
and some new user signs up for whatsapp
and what they'd like to do currently
their phone has a list of phone numbers
with people they know and they'd like to
automatically have all their existing
contacts imported into whatsapp
but the problem here is that we don't
the cell phone itself doesn't know how
to find they just have a list of phone
numbers they don't know how to find him
on the website after himself and so
currently one of the standard approaches
when a device things up they send all
their contacts to the website servers
and then they what's up servers sends
back the corresponding web sacked
contacts but then what's that sort of
sees who everyone's friends are or
contacts are across the whole like all
society almost because even if you don't
sign up for whatsapp maybe your friend
does
and then now what's up knows your
location and so to get around this we
can just run private set intersection
where only the phone would win who are
their whatsapp contacts and whatsapp
doesn't win anything at least initially
the core challenge in this scenario and
why many of the existing protocols don't
work very well is that the number of
whatsup users is massive
maybe I'll close to a billion not quite
sure what their user numbers are but we
can sit and say it's something like that
yeah while the phone only has you know
maybe a thousand contacts and so
traditional as we'll see you later
traditional protocols require
communication proportional to both sets
so this ends up being a big problem if
you want to actually deploy this because
phones aren't willing to download
gigabytes worth of cryptographic
protocol to be an assumption but we're
far from the first so here's a sort of
history of psi and I think I really like
private set intersection because they're
such a diverse set of cryptographic
primitives I've been used to construct
psi protocols and here's here I'll go or
something like the main general
techniques some of the original
protocols were based on diffie-hellman
and they use somehow used if you he'll
meant to create these like pseudo random
values which then are safe to compare
another line of work considered the
observation that you can encode sets as
polynomials or where each item is a root
of the polynomial and then you can sort
of do polynomial operations to be able
to compute a set intersection in some
way so it's been several works
considering this of course you can do a
generic secure computation and
surprisingly even if you use garbled
circuits at least back in 2012 you
actually get very good performance this
might not be the case anymore but at
least in 2012 even some circuits were
competitive but then sort of came along
this idea of using this data structure
known as a bloom filter which was a nice
technique and still used in some
settings but definitely the most common
approach has been techniques based on
primitive of oblivious transfer this is
where it say the most recent a line of
work is really focused but we took a
different approach is that and that we
started with fully homomorphic
encryption as I sort of pool our hammer
and we when looked for psi nails and so
we had a paper in 2017 and then another
paper in 2018 messes improves and
optimizes competence so we'll be talking
about these two stupid
and yeah and then here is just a
sampling of how many psi papers there
have been over over the years that I
have actually at least looked at each
other there's many more and so you can
see it's a very rich area research fun
to work on okay so back back to our main
application why why is this this
scenario with a symmetric set size is
difficult to do using like existing
codes of ethics
apart from that fit you well in this
case so here is a you know thousand
thousand mile view of how most psi
protocols work so first one party in
this case what's app servers will sample
a key okay and then they'll run some
sort of fancy cryptographic encoding
protocol where the other party inputs
have set Y and in back in return they
get an encoded version of all the
elements in one under that key K how
exactly this including works differs but
this is basically just it and then the
website what's up side will encode their
set X under this key K and so you can
think of a business like a PRF if you
want something like this and then and
then it's safe to simply send X Prime
the encoded version of X to the other
party and then they can locally
intersect these two encoded sex and then
map that back to the underlying Alliance
and so basically if
protocols first sample this key K and
then encode the large set and so
whenever you do this there's sort of
fundamental limitations that this
encoded large set has to be proportional
in size to the original set yet if we
just consider like if you do not don't
consider security like what could you do
well you could send a small set to big
success ID and then leave the
intersection send it back and so clearly
we'd like to achieve something with
communication complexity more
proportional list which is proportional
for small systems and the question is
can can we achieve this and considering
that we've been talking about full
helmet encryption for the last few days
everyone should know that in theory yes
you can easily get communication
complexity in proportion to its mule
spice you just simply encrypt the small
step size you can form encryption send
it to the server and they compute the
intersection send however in practice we
all know that fully homomorphic
encryption can be difficult to work with
if you're just running generic
algorithms in fact they can be very
small so we'd like to get both low
communication complexity and good
efficiency so that like you could
actually run this contact discovery
application in real-world snares and we
almost achieve amendment communication
complexity and
yeah I guess at this point does anyone
questions and then we're gonna jump into
I'll just okay so first what we do is
we're going to need a data structure
known as a cuckoo hash table cuckoo
hashing and what this allows us to do
it's going to allow us to look up items
into the constant time lookup as we'll
see so say we have items 1 through y1
through yn and we'd like to construct a
hash table we find these items quickly
and what we'll do is we'll use some hash
function H and we'll get these hashes of
each item and then these hashes will
point into the hash table and then we'll
stick by one and it's okay of course my
annotation and so forth pretty simple
hash table so far but eventually what
will happen is that two items in this
case y 1 and y n will be mapped the same
hash table location and there's various
ways to take care of this you can just
store both of them there but waiting
roll will have reasons you don't want to
sort both here and so we needed to
somehow resolve this collision between
these two machines um so the way we do
this is that we define a second hash
function H 1 and H 2 and when we get a
collision we evict the old item and then
we look at its new hash function
location and second one and that might
land at some other collision and we
continue through evict the old one until
eventually we'll get hopefully we'll get
a configuration whether it's exactly one
item birthday
and you can show that if the number of
Bin's is like 1.5 times the number of
items then using this hash this cuckoo
hashing technique will succeed with
overwhelming probability and then we can
ask okay we have some item X and we want
to look see whether X is in the hash
table well it's pretty easy we just look
at the two locations that X gets mapped
to and if X is in the set of Y then
these one of these two spots will hold
next the next primitive that we need its
folio math encryption I think everyone
at this point is familiar just a few
things I'd like to point out is that
additions are very cheap
we don't almost consider them free but
multiplication is really really where
things get expensive and not only is
multiplication than expensive operation
but we're also depth limited because we
actually don't use folio homomorphic
encryption we use some light or level
homomorphic
so so here like if you want to multiply
eight eight values together you can form
like a tree and do subsequent
multiplications in a treat my entry
fashion and so we'll be doing
computations like this but for to
achieve practical efficiency we have to
restrict ourselves to not go beyond
depth sticks of course you can go beyond
this but then the number of
multiplications we're going to be doing
is like billions and so if our if we do
go much beyond six the performance
computation performance of doing all
these multiplications we'll just so
we're really trying to one of the main
challenges is to describe a circuit
which doesn't have high def while still
computing our set intersection function
okay so first thing I'm it as a warm-up
we will consider that the scenario where
one party has y and the other party has
X two single elements and we want to
check whether they equal to each other
this is sort of like a set intersection
of size where this exercise
and how might you do this well first one
of the parties will encrypt the element
Y and send it over and now a simple idea
would be okay take Y and subtract X and
send it back and it's easy to see at
least for correctness if Z equals zero
then that means X equals y it's very
easy but if it's pretty it's not too
hard to see that this also has security
issues and that the receiver can
trivially recover the other item X this
by undoing the computation
so we need to somehow randomize Z and
the way we're going to do this is we're
going to require that the plain text
space is some field Z P and then and
then what we're going to do is sample
non random or non zero element R and
then we're going to multiply that with
the difference is two out of this and
what we get is if X minus y is 0 then
this Z stays zero otherwise multiplying
by this R gives you a beautiful new
random element from that's nonzero so
it's perfectly hide sort of information
theoretically
and so yeah that's a very simple
equality test
and then the question is how can we
extend this to the scenario where one
party holds set X so the sender holds a
set X and then we see there just holds
one item I why well we basically run the
same protocol again but instead of just
subtracting one of the X values we take
the product of all the differences and
now if any of the differences are or if
any x equals y then one of these
differences will be zero and then the
product will be 0 as the 1 and then
again will randomize the result so that
we don't week since it's information on
the sides great this seems like we're
making really good progress where
there's sort of one issue here is that
if you recall I said we can't go our
depth of our computation can't be very
high and say say we have the set X has
size big n and they to the power 28
close a quarter-billion and then this
would mean the depth of this circuit to
compute Z would be roughly depth 28
which is well beyond our sort of depth
on it for practical performance at leas
so the first thing we will need to do to
go around this is first sort of change
how we're looking at this and first
observed that this computation it can be
written as just a normal polynomial as a
function of X sex so we can just take
the set X and then sort of expand it in
its polynomial form to get these
coefficients a 1 or a 0 through a n user
X and then
we can simply do so evaluate the
polynomial but we haven't gotten around
the issue in that we still need to
compute Y to the power N and this again
naively if you just do the classic
square multiply algorithm yes would we
still require depth 28
so the next question is how do we get
get around this issue and we use a not
too uncommon technique known as I know
as when doing and here great our desire
is to compute the power of Y to the end
with some cynics line
and the solution we just saw is you know
you multiply you square u square and
then you can continue doing this and
building up the power in the expo
another sort of trivial solution in
depth to zero solution is instead of
sending why we send all the powers of y
and then we the sender can just simply
pick out the one that it meets but again
this has issue is that your
communication complexity is now
proportional to the large size that's
which we want to avoid
and more generally there's actually a
smooth sort of spectrum between these
two extremes and the one we choose is
you don't send all the powers you send
the log end powers as shown here and
what this allows you to do is then you
can take these powers of Y and you can
combine them to compute all the powers
that you're interested in and
importantly the depth of this circuit is
log log and so this is like basically a
constant for us and definitely below our
depth loonatics
an example of this is if we want to
compute Y to the power 7 you can just
combine these three times and so if we
before if we had depth 28 now we have
depth 5 which is and the communication
overhead is not too much we only require
now sending log n size of X which is
acceptable
so now let's take a look at our
membership test instead of just sending
why we're gonna send the powers of Y and
then we'll expand to get all the powers
of Y and then we'll evaluate this this
polynomial
and since since though each individual a
is known in the clear
these are basically all these eight
multiplications are basically linear
operations and so the only the only like
homomorphic oil market operations that
we need is when we are keeping all the
Y's expanding and so we did the
computational overhead is proportional
to the wide set size good depth and good
communication and so it's it's great so
now if we have a protocol for testing
whether a single element set wise in
large set X we can simply repeat this
further called many times right that
would be functionally correct at least
but the problem here is that if the
small size little n then we'd get
quadratic overhead in terms of
computation which you know if you have a
say a thousand items on the small side
and no quarter billion on the other side
that quickly becomes impractical and so
the question is how do we how do we get
around this quadratic
and this is where we are going to use
cuckoo hashing
so here the party with the small set
sides wise that comes first construction
cuckoo hash table where exam oh s--- one
item is in in given pin and then the
sender will place each of his items at
both hash function locations so here you
can see X one is in the second bin and
in the fourth thing because that's the
two locations of the hash function
mapped it to and so we have a guarantee
that if some say Y n equals x 1 then yn
will be in one of these two locations
too and so if we just do a membership
test per bin sort of then then we will
get the final result that we desire and
if in the case when X is much larger the
size of X is much larger than the size
of a lie
our sort of diagram with a more like
this where you have a single item and
you're conveying it to roughly big n
over little and other items and so the
overall complexity when you repeat this
protocol n times is proportional to the
large size size so we just shave dr.
fector like a couple thousand and so
things are starting to look very good
and this is sort of our basic protocol
at least on intuitive level by the wrist
still have a lot of work to do if you
want to get great performance
we do as I'm sure everyone has seen many
times in this as we apply this idea of
FHM batching and here great FEG
ciphertex can actually support many
plaintext slots in a single ciphertext
and so we just simply take advantage of
this for instead of the crypt encryption
each Y individually we encrypt them as a
vector and then we'll send that over and
we'll do vector operations just to the
exit columns and so basically but we
still run in the same exact algorithm
but now we're doing this component Y
vector education we check whether each
spot of their resulting type X Z is
equal to zero
but one one thing to notice here is that
our communication complex or
communication going in one direction
versus the other is sort of very
asymmetric and so are the back
communication is still of like sort of
constant size but our four communication
is logged in and so this raised the
question is can we so slightly increase
the amount of communication that we send
back not more than the first message but
that will allow us again to decrease the
depth and improve the computational
performance
and so that's exactly what we do we sort
of split the big set X into s partitions
then we run we run basically the same
out algorithm s times s copies of it and
we send them all back and so if you make
s say log big n then our your asymptotic
communication has not increased it's
still fortunately a lot of the big set
yet your depth of your circuit just
decreased and in particular the depth of
the circuit is now big n over or log log
again over little n times s so if we
practice this can get us our depth now
down to like three which is sort of wild
when you think you're comparing you know
a quarter billion items to
and then I'm not going to go into it
here but we also describe maybe not to
on one standard approach of that you can
compress these back ciphertext using
some fhe techniques so that they get
smaller
and this slide you actually can get
better coupons so it's a lot of a lot of
combining all the tricks have not robots
I try to really optimize this puzzle
so what we end up with here at the end
is sort of computation complexity
portion of a large set good
communication and and yeah and very
small depth and moreover an interesting
property of this is that I guess f-18
general is that all almost all the
computation is being performed at this
sort of large set size so in the case of
our conduct discovery this is some large
server at whatsapp data center and while
the the cell phone is only doing
encryption decryption so they form
almost no computational
yeah so there's a question on this pool
is how do you split information in X 1
to X 3 into these splits so before we
just had a large large data set here in
this case when we run those sort of this
the plane algorithm we just have a large
data set where there we represented
things in these columns and so when we
do the split it sort of just arbitrary
splits and we just just take the first
you know so many columns of X when we
batch them sort of just logically put
them together and and then we just run
the same algorithm several times and so
there's nothing sort of special about
these splits we just take the desired
number of items per slit but and sort of
logically group them together and then
we repeat the computation times
and so yeah or you can just view it as
like you know you we run the algorithm
in parallel sometimes on some sets but
yeah so each players of equal size so if
you did a quick question you know the
fact that you're using cuckoo hashing
yes do you have to worry about leakage
of information potentially you know
because the hashing table might become
full and you know that you know you need
to redo the hash table and that depends
on data right yeah you do have to be
very careful when you're using hashing
and there's - yeah there's two sort of
avenues of leakage one is if you fail to
insert all the items like you have some
set which just happens to not kuru hash
into this hash table for these getting
functions and high functions however
this problem can be getting rotten
around by simply ensuring that the hash
table is sufficiently large such that
with overwhelming probability for any
hash function you choose it will succeed
and so we simply sort of compute bounds
on how largest hash table needs to be
and writing practice and find it like
1.5 small okay the the other source of
leakage that you have to be careful when
using kuku hash table is that the
position that an item ends up in is so
that is a function of the rest of the
set right thanks and so if you can tell
whether some item was in if the party
here with the large set to tell whether
Y is in the first spot or in the second
spot that can lead to information too
and so yet the ease of careful about
these two caveats but here ends up not
matter
why can't you send more programs or
queries in case that items don't fit
into the Congressional in fact you could
do this you could decrease you could you
could make your cuckoo hash to go very
base Compaq and then you have multiple
copies of it and in fact one way to do
this is and instead of having the
proportional sort of end slots you could
have n over log n slots and then you
could repeat the protocol log log times
where you do just have multiple copies
and this is called the simple hashing
psi literature but in the end this
actually gives you worse performance
because you have to do so me replication
or we get to repeat the protocol so many
times log n times say which in practice
two greats performance and so cuckoo
hashing ends up being sort of a sweet
spot where you get a compact hash table
and you only have to run the protocol
once
you
so now we're sort of moving on to our
second paper which considers which end
up getting sort of better security
against malicious parties and in while
doing this we actually in seriously
so first let's consider the case when we
have a malicious deceiver and the only
thing that they do in this protocol to
send encryptions of their
item why and here we're just doing the
membership test for a simplicity where
they'll receive a visa garden and so
pretty much the only option that the
receiver has to cheat is somehow create
add ciphertext in some in someone maybe
they're not powers the correct powers
maybe the cyber takes I'm gonna form who
knows and of course you could slap zero
knowledge proof and all these things
which you know might not be too bad but
would definitely decrease performance
instead we take a sort of different
approach so first I'll need to induce
this idea of a puree OPRS
protocol and I kind of describe this
early on as this encoding function but
here's an explicit example of one of the
encoding functions they're critical and
the ascender on the left samples a key K
and the receiver sample makes inputs
Airwalk oh my and the key is input 2 and
then the receiver gets output PRF F with
the key K evaluated on the item Y and
then using this OPR F you can repeat
this many times if you want the desire
menu ice and then you classic
instructions will privates tender
section is then as I sort of described
earlier is that you encode the large
stacks under the PRF key and send that
over into clear and since PRF sort of
effectively randomizes on all other
values that aren't in the set why the
6/9 nation
other than intersections but as I
described earlier the main issue in the
per our setting at least with doing this
protocol is that this second message is
is large proportional avoids
oh oh but one a nice advantage of this
protocol is that if the OPF protocol is
malicious secure as from here in this
case then then the overall protocol is
malicious again so you sort of easily
get malicious security when you were
running a protocol with this
so we observed this and said okay can we
just use first run the OPRS protocol to
sort of encode the plaintext sets
x and y into x hat and y hack and then
we'll run our semi honest
yes high protocol on these encoded sets
and now you can you can ask well what if
the receiver sends some bad size of X
well we don't really care because
instead of we could have just sent the
encoded set X hack in the clear to the
receiver and so no matter what function
the receiver ends up making us compute
it doesn't matter because it won't week
any information beyond this pinchy
session itself
at this point you kind of if you look at
this long enough you realize that this
second protocol is actually a useful
form up here
in fact keyword Pierre where receiver
has some element why and they want to
look up whether y is in some database X
hi and just check whether it's there so
this is exactly the keyword peer
primitive and we just want to check
whether X is in
at this point we've started like wow we
actually created your protocol you just
a No
yeah and so that's how we get Moises
spit again study zero
now
to the case when we want moisture
security against a sender and here we
don't quite get close we get something
reasonable and since it's sort of
inspired since we have since we're now
using effectively a peer protocol to
retrieve the items we do something sort
of curious instead of just having the
encoded X hat we actually encode them as
pairs key value pairs where the key is X
hat and then the value is like a random
Oracle hash that's some complicated
function page but it will end the
meeting and so now the we perform peer
on these keyword pairs and if the y is
in the set X then what we'll get out of
the keyword peer is the hash of Y hat
otherwise we get sort of I didn't didn't
repeat and so now the question is how
could a malicious sender cheap well what
they might do one of the classic attacks
is that they simply maybe make the
receiver output their say and they
always output everything so the
intersection is always anything but now
if the if you wanted to do this it's
actually quite difficult so if we inline
our protocol again get rid of the pure
abstraction the what the receipt say the
the malicious sender wants to force some
widely in the output then what they need
to do is they need to compute this hash
function value I've only given Y hack or
the powers of it but since this
computing you know say sha-256
on a fhe ciphertext is extremely
difficult and requires a hot very high
depth circuit even giving these powers
it's very hard to compute given just
white encryptions of Y hat to compute
shot 256 of Y hat typically our fhe
parameters are extremely simle small
where you only keep perform a fuse
multiplications before the ciphertext
annoys o-over ends it and so typically
we say that you know it's sort of a bug
that we can't do arbitrary depth
computation using somewhat homomorphic
encryption but now we're going to use
this so there as a feature where it
prevents the malicious sender from
computing these hash values unless they
actually know the underlying value as
which is effectively means it's in their
set and and so
effectually prevents the sender from
this forcing the receiver to outputting
a full set in the clear it's the engine
there's some caveats here and we don't
quite achieve like the normal motion
simulation do security but it's sort of
an interesting idea
so the advantages of this sort of
two-phase protocol is that we Cecchi
this notion of malicious security the
second advantage that's not quite as
obvious is that the first protocol
actually required this notion of circuit
privacy where you have to flood the
noise in the ciphertext before sending
back but now we don't require circuit
privacy because this X hat value can be
into the public are you going and so we
can use extremely air bones fhe
parameters and this actually gives us
better performance than if we hadn't run
the opr protocol at all much less even
in the semi-auto set and sort of using
this key abstraction kind of get a
simpler interface and then the final
thing is that this some opr protocols
allow you to sample okay once and then
you can run encode many items and so
what stay in the whatsapp scenario is
they would first encode there pick a key
k then encode their database once and
for all under this PRF PK and then they
can just on-demand run this interactive
opf protocol with any client needed
which has small communication and then
run the Pierre part and so the cost of
running that opra sends up sort of
disappearing in an amortized setting
where you have many clients the
advantages that now we have to run this
propionic scheme do you do you use yeah
so if you're going to run this protocol
many times with many clients it's best
to use a deep like a DD h based o PRF
but if you're just gonna run the
protocol once you can actually use a
slightly weaker primitive a more
efficient based on the blue this
transfer was like a vast disappear X and
then you can only really need like so
much a key and then a 1 another
extension that sort of immediate is that
now that we have we're delivering labels
like this H hash function value as a
label for our PR queries we can actually
stick extra data in there so maybe you
know these this is the public key of
your friend that you're trying to
retrieve from what
and so you can simply check whether the
hashes match and then you can see the
corresponding there of course on
Colicchio what how you look them up in
the website summary and then a simple
trick that I don't necessarily want to
get into too much is that we can
actually facilitate some sort of secret
shared output where for each peer we
mask the database with some random value
are on each record and then we can look
at what we get as output we hit this
value Z which is you know the hash of Y
X or the value or penedo with the value
X for this randomness so Z and AR are
the now secure shares and some sort of
secondary MPC you can check whether the
hashes match and then recover the
corresponding value and so this way you
can get like instead of computing the
intersection you can compute the sum of
the values and into intersection or
something back and moreover the
communication complexity is still
proportional to the small set times
sizes of likes
and so this sort of gets us our wide
range of applications of the living room
so wrapping up here is a sort of diagram
of the performance of our protocol so
there so over here on the right we have
several protocols so these two at the
bottom ours is the green one with high
Oren communication for running that
excuse me this is based on fhe and this
I kept a chief a spear and it you can
see that it does achieve very low
communication but the computation to do
like a real world size contact discovery
five thousand verses 16 million requires
good six 16 seconds which could be
paralyzed on the server side another
peer like psi protocol is known as peer
psi but this is a to serve a pure
construction and in this scenario get to
server peer completed much more
efficiently and so you can see you get
better better anytime but there there
are security model is significantly
weaker it requires a to not including
peer servers which is sort of a unusual
assumption in practice versus ours
achieves like a normal notion of
security without any inclusion
assumptions there are also several
question yeah could you you you you do
have two parties here in this in this
scenario right could you imagine to be
implementing let them letting them be
the two servers and the yeah the the
issue is that most of these peer-to-peer
protocols require both both these two
parties to hold the data set right
exactly okay all right and so there's
sort of a chick chicken an egg because
the client doesn't have to be this way
so there are the truth not including
service I each have a copy of whatsapp's
contacts I see so you're saying you know
so there are these protocols you know
like you know boy or girl boy shy type
protocols that use it FSS more generally
- what to do - body cavitation with
small communication right but you're
saying the communication is proportional
to the sum of the input lengths as
opposed to the minute of the input
lengths where which is in the fhe case
right so you really like that one of the
sets is small mm-hmm yeah exactly yeah
and this pure psi protocol actually does
use that function supertrain okay okay
cool things so that so yeah the in this
blue range is where the the low
communication so the sub linear
communication or psi protocol sorry and
then you can see the result of having
these other protocols up in this top
range have the linear communication and
you can see that the communication
complexity is a here we're on a fast
Network land network so you don't see
the overhead of actually sending this
data especially if you consider like a
cell phone um this is just peer running
time and versus communication and so
even though this like our 8:18 protocols
quite fast in terms of efficiency they
just sending the data and then would end
up blowing up the running time and make
it worse and and so that's a shown here
yeah so that's sort of like the main
difference if you're willing if you're
willing to do linear overhead then
there's faster protocols but if you need
sub linear communication then these fhe
unless you can do not collision
assumptions
and uh yeah so that's I guess the
takeaway and I think the other takeaway
is that you know if it takes 16 seconds
on like a single thread server and only
you know 16 megabytes you could easily
run this in like a what's up scenario
where you just and with an actual
scenario because like you'd only need to
run this protocol maybe when you sign up
or for what stuff the first time it may
be occasionally afterwards and so it's a
it's definitely practical signal was
looking at this type of stuff but they
end up going with an SGX based solution
or wrote about nested a solution and I
thought they should have done this
that's okay yeah with that what's
everything so thank you
[Applause]
thanks Peter so any any more questions
for Peter
so let me ask me ask you something
so you mentioned SGX at the you
mentioned a sort of signal at the end
happened to read the blog a few months
ago and and I was thinking of sort of
the same thing you know what you know
why not use this bit so do you know do
you know why they went with the yeah
okay which I imagine is probably more
efficient than then-then-then
psi Frank yeah it's nothing more
communication efficient
I think they are as methodically is are
still quadratic in computation but it
ends up not really not too much I think
one reason they did that is at the time
of them writing that blog post it was
only our first protocol had just been
released and so there the performance
wasn't quite as good and it had some
constraints in various places and then
we came out with this and we talked to
him a little and they seemed like maybe
the computational overhead is still a
little bit large if you want to run it
at global scale I don't know it's it's
hard to say I see so say the signal
example the phone would my phone would
be the small set right and have this
month and I'm yeah and in the signal
example what you do is you send a small
set to the server SGX unit and then in
sort of batches you run the full or in a
streaming fashion you run the full
server-side data set through the s
checks and I could and then you just
record which ones ever match inside down
click and then they see send that back
so I guess that would be of the order of
maybe an order of magnitude maybe two
bigger than right I mean sodium yeah I
think if you look at the peer psi
protocol it is a basically doing the
same thing in terms of computational
load and so I think it'd be on order of
this P or psi but they get one server
coming so you can see maybe that would
give you an idea yeah once ever but
trust right yeah machine yeah I also
heard they're not making my
cancellous Jax oh yeah there are no
other questions so let's thank Peter
again and uh Jessica surrenders our next
speaker and she will speak in about 21
minutes at 12:15 Pacific thank you